is going to be spectacular absolutely
amazing we're going to create hundreds
of local jobs you guys are going to do
that we're going to attract visitors
from all around the world because what
you're going to create here is going to
be world class and we're going to make
sure that we Inspire so many people to
think about our natural world and help
tackle and solve some of the challenges
of climate change and we're going to do
that right here in your hometown so it's
a brilliant example of what our leveling
up agenda is all about it's not just
talk it's about action but what does it
mean what does leveling up mean because
you hear it a lot
now for me it's something very simple
it's about spreading opportunity and
creating jobs in every single part of
our country but it's also about making
sure that people wherever they live in
our amazing country can feel huge Pride
enormous pride in the places that they
call home and this project this
investment is a fantastic example of us
delivering that for all of you now when
we David and I were out and about this
morning I you know I sense there was so
much excitement there was a real Buzz
about what this project means for your
community and that's why it's a real
privilege for me to be with you today to
celebrate your success I'm really proud
to be able to bring the investment to
you I'm proud to back all of you and
your amazing community in this wonderful
project and the thing that you're going
to create for us all to enjoy and that's
what gives me confidence that when we
work together we really can change our
country for the better and we took an
enormous step on that Journey today with
all of you so thank you for that that's
all I wanted to say oh God thanks David
right
that I am mainly here I am mainly here
to actually just answer some of your
questions while we're in town we thought
it'd be a nice idea to come out and and
hear what you wanted to put to me so I'm
here whatever you want to ask feel free
don't be shy political personal all the
rest of it and nothing off board now I
think we have got a first question
um from is it Emma is that right who yes
brilliant
hi hello
um so I'm from Lancaster at Morgan
college and I think it's fantastic how
the Eden Project has been incorporated
into the curriculum for my course which
is animal management
um my question is how are you going to
engage students from other subject areas
within the college
you know that's it everyone can and hear
the question about engaging young people
in in the projects that we announced
today and others it's a brilliant
question right because when I talked
about leveling up I talked about
creating jobs and opportunity and I
represent a rural area in the north of
England as well and what I want as a
member of Parliament and what I want my
government to deliver is to ensure that
especially all of you especially all of
you in the front row who are all local
and studying locally that no one feels
they have to leave home to fill and
fulfill their dreams right that's a
really simple thing right all of you
have got massive Ambitions for your
lives what you want to do with your
lives and what I want is you to be able
to do that at home right I don't want
you to have to move away and if you want
to that's fine but you shouldn't have to
and I think for too long people felt
they had to particularly if they didn't
live in London and the South and I don't
want that to be the case and that's why
these projects are really important that
we're announcing today and it's why it's
so important as you said that we are
connected with what we're doing with
what you want to do and talking to
talking to your college leader earlier
it's brilliant that that's happening
actually because it's all very well
we're going to create these jobs we need
people to do them and we want you to
benefit from them so what we do up front
when we ask these guys to submit their
bid to us and we decide who are we going
to fund one of the things we look for is
is that happening are the local
education establishments whether their
colleges whether they're universities
whether they're schools have they been
included in the bid are they talking to
the council who are putting in the
application have they thought about
actually if they say they're going to
create all these jobs for us that
they've figured out they've got the
right courses for all of you to do to
benefit from those jobs and it's one of
the things that we look at and your guys
and he's nodding there because he
deserves a praise you did it brilliantly
here and when I was talking to some of
you earlier I can see that you're really
pumped but that's what it's about it's
about making sure that you can fulfill
all your dreams all your aspirations and
you don't have to leave home and I
really think because of this project
here today we're going to make a reality
of that and when I come back and visit
it in a couple of years it'll be working
on this site and it's going to be superb
so best of luck with it
right okay so let's go who's next yes
ma'am
hey the question to you today is just
what impact do you think people have on
the visitor economy both here in
Morecambe and on The Wider area uh
there's a cumbrian economy over to the
Lakes do you think it'll increase dwell
time for visitors to the area yeah I
mean it was it was one of the things
that actually David talked a lot about
in Parliament and and the bid talked
about it the exciting thing about what
this is going to do here is it's not
just a local attraction right what this
is it's not even just a regional
attraction quite frankly it's not even a
national attraction it is a world-class
attraction and that's what you guys are
going to do here you're going to create
something the likes of which is going to
be appealing to people all around the
world and that's what's so exciting and
you're also lucky because we look we've
done this in Cornwall right we've got an
Eden project in Cornwall it's amazing
you're going to benefit from all of that
and the team already thinking well how
do we take what we learned there and
make sure that we can do things
differently and better here this time
around and what we've seen there is it
does do exactly that it increases visits
to the area not just from the region not
just from the country but from around
the world and then this is a great
springboard to go and visit all the
other places in the north actually when
we were standing at the top of the hotel
and you can see the lake district and
the Yorkshire Dales which is over where
where I live in North Yorkshire what a
great what a great place right what a
great place to come to learn to explore
how we interact with nature take a
concert at the new venue that's going to
be there but then also go off and
springboard into everything else so I
think it's going to be brilliant for the
visitor economy we've already seen that
that's happened down south and now it's
going to happen for you here and that's
going to be great for all the local
businesses local jobs the pubs the b b's
the restaurants the cafes everything
else and that really drives a local
economy so that's our vision for what's
going to happen good right okay let's go
uh let's go over here yes sir
had a IDs or something
so are you are you from the media I
think we were going to try and do some
media questions at the end if you don't
mind so let's try and actually just
let's get it where should we go let's go
over to the to the back yes ma'am
um
really an opportunity to support
fantastic Investments with the
promotions
oh that's a that's a great question okay
so let me take that away because we
should do more Regional tourism and I
mean I I will have to I have to be
careful in uh in your in your presence
but I'm obviously very proud of the
Yorkshire brand that I I benefit from
and I I try and Champion around the
world but but that's right I mean like
if you know if we're trying to appeal to
people around the world actually yes of
course they should come visit the UK
overall but actually we can put a
picture together to come and visit you
know whether it's Lancashire whether
it's Yorkshire whether it's the North
and dcms should do a good job of that so
let me take that away and make sure that
we can find out how to do that but I
think to be honest when you do that
having a signature attraction like this
is probably really important to making
it a success right because someone could
want to come to the UK just because of
this project at the end of the day right
so we've got to use that so it can
benefit the entire region here and we
should think about how to do that
intelligently uh with our tourism money
and how we structure all the tourism
agencies but also it's a great idea I'll
take that away right over here yes ma'am
hi Joe hi
um in Project Malcolm brings together
economic regeneration with Nature's
recovery and we all know that um being
time spent outside is really good on
health impact for people so in the
leveling up Bill is there going to be
Provisions that allow
um more access to Green spaces for all
individuals to help reduce inequalities
yeah so it you know it's a really
important point and we know that power
of green and open spaces for people's
General well-being for their health or
their mental health or their Fitness and
just because it's a lovely thing to do
right and we all get pleasure from being
outside particularly on an amazing day
like today so one of the things we've
done which we've already announced and
we're getting in the process of rolling
out are are something which we used to
call them pocket parks and I think
they're now called leveling up Parks
because we've branded everything
leveling up but what these are actually
are where the government will provide a
small Grant to local communities to
create green spaces particularly in
those parts of the country that don't
often have them I think if you think of
big City areas particularly in areas
where there's more deprivation we're
actually creating those green spaces is
really needed you talked about kind of
closing the inequality Gap there so that
Pockets Parts Program was one of my
first ministerial jobs I used to be
local government Minister and that's
where I came across it and we did more
of it because it works brilliantly and
it works brilliantly whether when it's
working together with local communities
actually because they want to you know
largely people are happy to pitch in
right they've got there's a patch in
their part of town that they think they
can do something more special with
engaged school children engage people
who are retired and they do it really
well and now you can get government
funding to help you do those types of
projects so you know it's small scale
but I often think these small scale
things that make a real difference to a
community that you can do relatively
quickly are the things that make the
most difference actually in how we feel
about life and close some of the
inequalities that you you talked about
so that I have a look at that online and
the next time we do one of those you
should if you've got an idea email it in
and see if we can help good right let's
go back uh we've got yes sir right at
the back
estate agents do you obviously this is
absolutely fantastic news great news for
the area do you have any time frames
yeah actually we were talking to the
team and we think it's about it's about
two years I think the time frame for
this particular project and that's
really what the fund is about actually
the leveling up fund is you know often
government is spending billions of
pounds on things that take decades and
by the time they're finished you can't
forget when they haven't started right
and who is responsible this this this
fund and this leveling up commitment is
about doing those I'd say you know this
is not small but smaller scale type
projects where you can see and feel the
change in your community quite quickly
and that's what we're really Keen to
deliver I will say like you know
government and I I mentioned at the
beginning about the things I want to do
for you like I Believe In Action right I
want to do things that you can hold me
accountable for actually delivering and
this project is one where look I you
know I talk to the team about like when
is this going to get done and one of the
ways when we allocate money actually and
where the team are figuring out well
which bids are successful or not one of
the criteria is deliverability it's like
actually are the team all connected
together have they talked to the private
sector as well and it's not just the you
know councils that are doing it have
they figured out how they can deliver
this thing and do it relatively quickly
and well that's actually how we score
the bids so it's it's key in about two
years I mean the team here locally will
probably be able to give you a more uh a
more specific answer but that's the
rough type of time frame and that's
pretty similar with all the fun things
that we're trying to fund over the
course of today
good right uh yes
hi Hannah from
Lancaster or moreham college and I'm
wanting to know what job opportunities
they'll be from the Eden project for
like students like us or like just the
public who are wanting to seek a job
yeah so there's I mean there's going to
be different types of jobs at different
different phases so what they're going
to be in the early phase are lots of
construction jobs actually and as you
build the project there'll be hundreds
of construction jobs that are needed and
actually Michael Gover was with me
earlier was visiting some of your
colleagues who are who are studying so
that's going to be great I think one of
them said to him I don't know who if
that person is here I think one of them
said he said I did this construction
apprenticeship I made the decision to do
it and now after today I think it's the
best decision I ever made I know that
person's here but um but that so that
works well and then obviously after its
bill then you know I'm not the expert
but the project team will be able to
tell you as well but as you know some of
us were talking before there'll be lots
of jobs actually involved in
conservation if you think about what the
Eden Project is I mean it's a
world-class attraction that talks about
our relation ship with nature and
because of that and actually because of
the research and some of the discovery
that will be going on there there'll be
some really exciting opportunities in
the natural world which so they won't be
available in many other parts of the
country so I think that's really really
special and then they'll of course be
all the hospitality jobs right when you
think at the end of the day we talked
about it right at the beginning like
there's visitor attraction visitor
economy all the people who have to do
marketing Finance accounts right all of
that all of that stuff so I think you
know all sorts of things which is going
to be great for all of you and everyone
else in the area I hope
right who have we got yes ma'am
thank you Carolyn Jackson has
another Council here so this is a
fantastic day I don't think I can think
of a better one for
ever and looking forward it's going to
change Morecambe we are so so happy to
be here and it's a great relief thank
you I'm finally actually saying it but
what I'd say to you is this credible in
energy enthusiasm Ingenuity fantastic
collaboration that's gone across the
sectors we've got our MP here working
with the council County Council uni you
know
we've got all this to offer
how are you going to pick this up
because leveling up comes once but how's
this immense possibility for this area
and across the Northwest and where you
are how's the north going to be picked
up and helped to really contribute to
the future of our nation the health and
the wealth because
we know you've got leveling up there
because we've been left behind and how
are you going to get that rolling
onwards because that's what we want to
do yeah no kind of well hey thank you
for what you said which was lovely and
I'm so glad that you you feel excited
about today because I think it really is
a day to celebrate and yours how are we
doing it I think you know we do it but
by actually just getting on and
delivering it is to be honest right we
can't just talk about trying to close
some of the gaps or change some of the
things that happen in the past we've
just got to actually do it in practice
which is what today is a great example
of and we're doing this across the
region and there's projects everywhere
that are probably having a similar Day
to you guys today but I think the other
thing we need to change because that's
all good and well right we can stand up
and we can ounce money in a project in a
particular place I think we've just got
also to change people's perception and
change their mindset and give people the
sense that actually for the first time
people talked about this in the past
that now someone's doing something about
it and that's what I'm trying to do and
that won't happen overnight if of course
change doesn't happen overnight but I
really feel when I'm doing my visits
across the north now that people do feel
that something has changed and you take
an area near me t-side which is a great
example which I know well because it
it's close to where I live right that's
an area which over the past several
years if you take go you know rewind
several years a steel plant closed until
in t side thousands of people lost their
jobs and you might at that point think
gosh what what's the future of our
region like what you know what does that
mean for us you know fast forward not
that many years it's just brimming with
optimism and excitement you know partly
because of some of the things the
government has done we've created a new
Freeport there we've we've they've got
funding from the infrastructure Bank
like you they've received funding for
their Town centers and high streets and
things like that the treasury that when
I was Chancellor we put a treasury
campus in Darlington you know that's
fine we've done our bit but actually
people in the region have taken that and
have been brilliant and are now just as
I said they're booming with ingenuity
and pride in their area that it's going
places that new jobs are being created
and I think that's a kind of positive
cycle so once we do one or two things
and people think okay change is starting
to happen it just Builds on itself and
that you get a virtuous circle then of
positivity and momentum to do new and
better things and I just want everywhere
to go through that process and hopefully
there were already so many good things
going on here but a project like this
now can kick-start a new sense of
forward progress right here right so
everyone can feel confident about the
future and I can see people nodding
which is great and then this will spur
other people to think about other things
and I think we can replicate that in
lots of places we'll be able to make the
change but I'm determined to deliver it
and you know I really think that
actually today and what we've done
previously is making a really a really
good stab at it and you'll see lots more
from us over the next couple of years
too
right who uh yes sir
hi John hi how secure is the additional
funding to complete this project in the
two-year time frame
so the funding from government is
completely and utterly secure now the
project team are in the process of
securing the other bits that they need
from different sources and some of that
will come from the private sector some
of it may well come from Pension funds
and other investors but I think one of
the big pitchers which we've always
thought about this project and what the
team have always said is look if the
government comes and shows its
commitment then actually that will
unlock private sector capital and I
think that's really important because in
a project like this needs to be able to
attract capital from other sources as
well if we think it's really going to
work and be successful but I think you
know I feel confident about that the
team feel confident about that as well
and we've done I think a very
well we made a very significant
statement today with what we've done and
I think as you say those conversations
now will be far easier with all the
other providers of of capital
yes ma'am
hi there I'm Sue and I work in a local
charity I work in the hospice and so
we're constantly looking for funding so
today was a great day I was so pleased
to hear the announcement but a little
inkling of worry about the funding it's
a continuation of that theme and that
this morning it was like the stars
aligned on the news wasn't it because we
hear that the king wants to give the
money from the wind farm that's just out
there in morecon Bay and I just suddenly
thought maybe that was an option oh yeah
you know so uh I haven't spoken to him
about that bit yet so
um no I know I haven't actually I
haven't seen the details of what's going
on but there's a there's a mechanism in
place for some of the the crown estate
things but I think I think look you
should feel confident because this is
such an exciting project and now that
the government has come in and put a
huge commitment behind it I think you'll
see actually lots of other sources of
capital unlock and other people will
want to be will want to be part of it as
uh want to be part of it as well but
thank you for what you're doing at the
hospice which is obviously uh amazing
work actually I was just in Northern
Ireland uh recently visiting their
hospice there and it you and your
colleagues who work in places like that
just do something that's very special
and very demanding but the people you
help are enormously grateful and we're
very lucky to have you do it
right yes ma'am
I wondered if you had any idea how a
project like this might address the
health inequalities that are so
prevalent in our community
yeah so I think well actually is that a
question that we had before about green
spaces as a good example that we know
that having access to more Open Spaces
more green spaces is good for people's
well-being their health physical fitness
but also their mental health and
actually this you know what's going to
happen here is going to be fantastic for
that and I always talk about some of the
pocket park things they all do the same
thing but more broadly you know I mean
it's probably good to talk about the NHS
a bit in general actually because I
you'll all know that the NHS is under
pressure and I just want you to know
that we in government recognize that and
we're doing everything we can to make
life a bit better now that's why in a
few months ago we had the Autumn
statement the chancellor stood up just
after I became prime minister and he had
to make and we had to make in government
some quite difficult decisions because
you you'll remember things it needed
settling down and calming down and we
had to get our borrowing and debt back
under control have a clear plan to
reduce inflation and that meant some
difficult decisions now we try to do
those as fairly as we could but as we
did all of those we prioritized the NHS
as I did when I was transfer and we put
more money into the NHS and it's
billions of pounds more over the next
couple of years but you might rightly
ask hang on you're saying you're putting
billions of pounds into this thing and
every time I turn on my TV screen it
seems like you know there's something
that's not quite working and that's a
combination of lots of things right
we've had a really tough flu season
covert is something that obviously we
are still recovering from and you know
we're not alone in that here in England
it's happening across the UK and funnily
enough and it's happening in other
countries as well it's not even confined
to the UK but let me tell you what we
are doing to to try and ease some of
those pressures and give you the
confidence that things will get better
so you know many of you will have
families that are waiting for operations
they're on a waiting list somewhere
right and the number is got now to
several million people right so you know
I would imagine if I asked you probably
lots of you will have a family member
that is waiting for something and we've
got a really clear plan in place to get
the numbers of people waiting down which
we're making progress on and that's
about doing things differently so for
things like hip operations for example
we're trying to separate those out from
the hospital right so the hospital's
dealing with lots of emergency care if
we can take things like hip operations
or indeed scans if you need a CT scan or
an MRI scan we can do those closer to
your home in a community in a new center
all of that means that we can keep
getting on with that treatment even when
the NHS gets busy and because we're
doing things like that we're able to cut
the waiting list and when it comes to
ambulances and Emergency Care the single
biggest thing we have to tackle is a
number of people in hospital and right
now our hospitals are really full partly
because of the winter and flu partly
because of covid and and what we need to
do as quickly as possible is for all the
people who don't need to be in hospital
who could be at home or in the community
in a social care setting we need to
support to get them there and we've put
some extra money in to do exactly that
and I think every week that goes by were
able to get people back to to their
homes and communities that eases up the
burden in hospitals and then just makes
everything in the hospital work a bit
quicker and easier in the a e department
and then ambulance is not waiting as
long so you know we're not going to get
there overnight but just rest assured
I'm spending enormous amount of my time
on it the other Saturday I had an all
day with all people from the NHS all
around the country and one of the things
we focused on was learning from all
those people who were doing it really
well so even though you look on your TV
and you might think God this is a
problem everywhere actually there are
lots of places around the country where
locally they figured out how to overcome
some of these challenges because the
team there have you know done something
different and have really overcome the
challenges and what we were trying to do
is identify all of those so that we can
take those ideas those ways of working
and spread them across the rest of the
NHS that everyone benefits and things
get better and in a couple of weeks I'll
be talking to you all about how we're
specifically going to do that in
emergency care so that you and then
again as I said over the course of this
year you should absolutely hold me to
account and when I come back here at
some point you can say How are you
getting on with that and I'm confident
that we'll be in a much better place
than we are today because I know it's
the most important public service to all
of you it is to me you know my dad was a
doctor my mum was a pharmacist I grew up
in an NHS family and I know how
important Healthcare is to the country
and that's why we're going to keep keep
going at it until it gets a lot better
right who's uh yes sir
nice to meet you Ryan Williams Lancaster
Morgan College
um I just want to say thank you very
very much for the support and the
investment into the into local area
equally David I suppose my question is
to help colleges and Fe colleges
continue to provide skills for the
future to grow the economy and is the
government committed to support in Fe
colleges and apprenticeships yes and yes
is the quick answer
um but so you know one of my views is
that you know in the past we spent a lot
of time talking about University and
that's great but we need to spend you
know as much if not more time talking
about all the other ways that people can
get the qualifications that they need
and that's something that I firmly
believe and what we're doing is kind of
reorienting the funding in our attention
to some of those other things whether
it's Fe colleges or apprenticeships so
you know what actually we have in place
are incentives for small businesses to
take on apprentices you go and have a
look at those online if any of you are
interested in taking on an apprentice
there's some government support for you
to do that Fe colleges are getting more
funding and they're also the other thing
we're doing is trying to improve the
quality of the actual colleges
themselves which were you know hadn't
got money for kind of repair and
maintenance for a long time so we're in
the process of improving the quality of
them which is nice so when you know you
guys will show up to study actually the
environment is a nicer place to study
and and then the other thing we're doing
which is a bit more radical is we're
totally changing how the student finance
system works right so you know when you
go to university now you get this
government provided loan it's you know
everyone can have it you don't have to
pay it back for a long time it comes on
a relatively preferential terms even
though I know people don't always think
that but what I want to do and what the
government is doing is changing that so
it doesn't it's not just there for you
if you're 18 and going to do a
three-year University degree if you're
25 if you're 35 if you're 45 and you
think hang on I actually want to go and
pick up a qualification right maybe it's
a level four qualification in cloud
computing maybe it's a you know level
four qualification or level three in
Veterinary nursing as we were talking
about before and you decide that later
on in your life you should still have
access to that type of funding and we're
changing the system over the next couple
of years so then people will be able to
do that because the way the economy
works is changing right and people will
change jobs more often and you know what
I want to make sure is that anyone who's
prepared to work hard if they want to go
and get some new skills so they can get
a better job or a new job earn more
money provide more to their family like
I want the government to have their back
right those you know all of you are
working hard and when you want to go and
do something more for your family like I
want to be right behind you and that's
why we're reorienting the finance system
so it does that for those people is
really important to me and that's how
we're going to make sure we just you
know we build a vibrant economy as well
because if we need people to be in the
right jobs doing the right things and
that's constantly changing but that's
it's an important thing for us to us to
deliver right we've got a couple I I
don't feel that you have to ask
questions just about Eden Project as
well if there's anything else on your
mind feel free to punch it in and then
we'll get we'll we'll wrap up in a bit
yes sir
my name is Mark I'm the chairman of
betaism Association again I want to
thank you for today's investment I think
you've realized the dreams of thousands
of thousands of local people today
um fantastic world uh beaten attraction
but the importance of having an
attraction like this is also the public
transport infrastructure that goes
alongside that people can't visit the
north of England if there's no efficient
transport system I just wondered what
the government plans are for that going
forward and yeah so well there's lots of
different things we're doing in
transport and they're all they're all
they're all slightly different right so
one is we just got to connect up all the
places across the country and one of the
big ways we've talked about doing that
is high speed 2 hs2 right which is going
all the way from London up north the
other thing is we need to connect up
across the north right and I know this
because I live on the other side of
penins and you know I know like when I
was where I am over at northallerton in
North Yorkshire getting up and down to
London is actually great right
relatively quick train work we're trying
to go you know over to Manchester is
much trickier right like that and that
that Journey time takes far longer it's
far less reliable than when I'm going
north south and I think one of the big
challenges and I'm sure you can see lots
of people nodding like one of the things
that you know you know because you live
here trying to get across the north is
not as easy as it should be so what we
announced uh was an enormous sounding
number the early last year was at 96
billion pounds it's kind of hard to even
know what to do with that number but it
represents the largest investment in
rail across the Midlands and the north
that this country's ever seen now that's
what I was talking about at the
beginning the things that cost billions
and take decades right that's not going
to happen overnight but it is big and
it's significant and almost any Journey
time that you look at you'll see that
it's going to shrink whether it's
East-West across the north across the
Midlands up and down North South so
that's helpful but then we also are
trying to do more Local transportation
which is actually the thing that people
like you ask me about as well in my area
it just needs to be easier to get around
and that's where we need to focus more
and as you guys talk about it we'll talk
about commute to college the thing that
you know makes opportunity real is for
people to be able to access it in their
area and that's about making sure that
in your area you can get to where the
jobs are from where you live and that's
about investing in local roads which we
do a lot more of repairing potholes
sounds simple but it's really important
but also doing more in things and buses
and Cycles all the rest of it we're
doing that but fundamentally making sure
that the road network works efficiently
everywhere and around our big city
regions are kind of eight big city
regions so whether it's greater
Manchester or Birmingham they're like
London right London got this special
deal where the mayor in London gets a
pot of money he gets to decide how to
spend it over a period of time and we
want that same type of funding and
powers to be in place all around the
country and all our big city regions to
make it easier for people to move around
them and we're something we have not
done brilliantly as a country in the
past and when someone's people look at
us to say hang on how come all these
other places aren't as productive as
long London in the way that across
Europe they often are other cities and
that's one of the reasons it's because
you know actually London has the tube
and the tube makes it very easy to get
from one end into the middle or one end
to the other you need to kind of
replicate that feeling in all our other
city regions and that drives a lot of
economic activity so over the course of
the next few years we'll be making some
progress on that as well
all right okay yes ma'am
ah thank you
um we have a fabulous bunch of ladies
and gentlemen working there and we've
had some fantastic figures for tourists
this year and on a selfish point we're
hoping that you know even we'll provide
us with a lot more
the thing is I was born in Malcolm so I
know the Heyday which was brilliant
thoroughly enjoyed it lots to do and
then the bad times with not lots to do
and we're just on a sort of smaller um
investment ideas for local people to get
the money to up their business we've
already seen over the past few years
that there's been new cafes new wine
bars Hotel expansions
um this was well before they knew about
the Eden so hopefully we're going to get
a lot more yeah and and are they going
to be guaranteed
some sort of money to do this you know
with a lot of empty space there's a lot
of empty shops and we need them filling
which we're hoping that we'll do I'm
sure they will it does seem a bit
chillish when you've just given us 50
million that's all right if you can just
get used to it can we have a bit more
yeah basically
um I know that we would appreciate it uh
you know very much because we need the
money yeah no that's right no harm in
asking
um so look look can we do a course we
can't do everything right I'd love to do
everything we can't I'd love that's why
as you can see actually and we talk
about it if you want it's we're having
some you know not easy conversations
with with unions about what's affordable
when it comes to pay right unfortunately
like government has a budget like all of
you in your homes and your businesses
and we have to make those decisions and
they're not easy but I what I totally
agree with you though is about having
really vibrant High streets and town
centers and all those businesses that
you talked about the pubs the cafes the
restaurants that's what gives a High
Street the vibrancy and the small shops
and I tell you what we are doing because
we are doing a few things that will help
with that and one is if you talk to it
I'm sure we have some of those
businesses here and you'll know them the
number one tax that they all hate is
business rates right it's business rates
is the thing for those shops and those
cafes I can see some of you nodding
which is good and so what what we've
announced over the last year and the
chance to announce for next year is a
big tax cut on business rates so if
you're a small Shop restaurant Cafe you
will get a three-quarters 75 discount on
your business rates bill
um next year right so starting in April
so that's really big it's really
generous it's worth thousands of pounds
to a typical Pub and that will really
help and the other thing we need to do
is actually it's a bit techy but it's
important right you you guys are all
changing how you shop right all of us
are right we're doing more online and
that has an impact on high streets so we
need to make sure that our high streets
adapt and evolve and that means changing
the planning laws which is what we've
done so that it used to be quite common
there'll be some councilors here more
familiar this than I am but it used to
be really tricky if you used to be a
shop in one place and then you wanted to
change it to make it into an office or
indeed put apartments or flats above the
top or change it into a you know
hairdressing all those things were a bit
complicated so we've changed the
planning laws to make it much easier so
as all of our habits evolve our high
streets are going to need to look
different and do different things
they're going to have less probably
shops selling things and more services
whether it's hairdressers nail salons
dentists whatever else my new the
scanners that I talked about where you
can go and get your MRI scan or your CT
scan it'd be great if you could just go
and do that on your High Street rather
than have to schlep over to the hospital
um so the planning rules that we've
changed will help those High streets
adapt and then the last thing is there
any specific money for them there is
actually so something called help to
grow and we should go and have a look
online and have a look at this program
called help to grow and what that is is
our business the support for small
businesses where they can receive some
grant funding if they want to improve
their business and grow and they've got
Ambitions to do more they'll get some
help and support on training or software
that will help them do that so that's a
specific program that you're going to
have a look at but let me know the
business rates cut is coming in a couple
of months and that should put some more
cash in their pockets and the chances
are also just announced some help with
their energy bills as well because
they've had some help at the moment and
then it was due to end and the
chancellor has announced it will carry
on with it won't be as generous because
we can't keep doing everything at the
same level but there'll be extra help
with their energy bills next year as
well but I think the most important
thing is because Eden Project North is
going to be here as you said it's going
to bring all these people here it's
going to bring the business and that's
the most important thing it's less about
what government is doing it's about
actually the fact that there was lots of
people here who need somewhere to eat to
stay to hang out and hopefully lots more
customers which would be very good news
right yes ma'am
hi I'm Laura donville Pony I'm a local
business owner
um I actually have a shop directly
opposite um where the Eden Project is
going to be built oh that's good news
which is fantastic great news but I'm
going to go a little bit left field as
anyone thought about the pressure on the
local rnli team when the um when the
tourism increases my son is actually
part of the rnl I put your hand up Luke
thank you thanks Mom
I just I wanted to know if anyone had
considered the added pressure that's
going to be on the local team well you
know what that's that's an excellent
question and what it why don't you if
I've got time offers that you should
come and have a chat with me and we
should make sure that we have thought
about it and we get you the support that
you need but thank you for the job that
you're doing as well because that is uh
that is brilliant I was um I thought I
was just in Scotland saying Northern
Ireland seeing their search and rescue
team and they were talking about their
interaction with your colleagues as well
and particularly in a place like this
superb right and if people are going to
come here and we need people to help
them out thank you to you for doing that
as well but I will pick that up with
Luke if that's uh if that's all right
and thank you for volunteering him for
that q a afterwards brilliant there was
a lady at the back I think and then I'm
getting waved at right so I better come
and take some questions from the media
as well
hi hi thank you so I'm flipper
Williamson leader of Lancashire County
Council thank you for your investment in
uh in Eden today but more widely than
that 220 million pounds across
Lancashire is just a fantastic uh boost
of confidence for us all and I hope that
confidence came through all the bids
that all the partners here most most of
them are here universities councils uh
um County Council third sector we all
come together and work really hard over
Eden for the last five five years
spearheaded by David doing this
cheerlead a bit in Western which is
great
but I I wanted to ask you really about
that the County council's bid was about
uh Greener safer more active travel
because we see that as really important
right you know of making little local
communities much more safe and easier to
walk about so you know interested in
your views and vision for that yes so
you know when we were talking to the
question earlier about transport that's
the local bit that I was talking about
out and it's you know actually whether
it's you know buses where we're doing
more of but also as you said active
travel and some of the schemes that
we've supported today uh are about that
funnily enough actually one of the ones
in my constituency as an active travel
component to it because that is
important and we had a couple of
questions about how does Health Connect
with all of this I think where people
can if they want to be out and about
doing that get some from A to B but also
good for their health and physical
fitness so it's it's very much part of
the plans and as you've seen some of the
projects today specifically have
benefited from active travel investment
others it's not my favorite thing to do
I am not I'm not big on the whole
cycling thing that's personal thing but
um and but we do need to make sure that
we do have it for those people who uh
who who want it which is why we're doing
we're doing some of it today but thank
you right okay I bet we better take some
questions from you is that all right
we're time wise okay Anushka you're a
veteran of these things gonna want you
kick us off thank you Anisha christana
ITV News prime minister you're obviously
giving money to Morecambe today but
you're also giving 19 million pounds to
reopen a castle in Canterbury while
Bradford and South tyneside have got
nothing is this what leveling up looks
like now and as part of that can I ask
you about the makeup of your cabinet
because it does have quite a heavy bias
to the south in fact you have more
cabinet members representing seats in
Surrey than the whole of the north of
England is that why leveling up is now a
little more focused on the south well
I'd say a couple of things anishka I
think look you if you look at the
funding that we've announced today in
the leveling up Finance with all of you
guys as well should hear this right so
we have these leveling up funds this was
this is the thing that we're announcing
today and then the best way to think
about it well how is each region getting
its share of this money and does it seem
reasonable the best way to think about
it is kind of to compare the money each
region is getting with the number of
people that it has right because
obviously some regions have got fewer
people than others and if you look at it
on that way so you say how many pounds
of investment per person in the region
what you find is that the North West is
the top region so the amount of money
per person living there who came top
Northwest who came second Northeast and
actually if you look down at the other
end of the table you find places like
London and the southeast and the
difference is huge so I think the
funding that you're all getting per
person out of this leveling up fund is
twice per capita what London Southeast
is getting and it'll actually give you
guys the confidence that when we talk
talk about delivering Levering up and
spreading opportunity across the country
that we really mean it and that's what
the numbers show look on on the cabinet
I you know I think most people just want
people who can get on and do the job and
deliver all these things and I've put
built a team around me of people because
I think they can help me deliver all
those things and that's what I'm focused
on them doing but I'd say one thing
because you talk about where everyone's
seats are that when I was Chancellor I
was probably the most northern sitting
Chancellor this country's had in some
decades I'm now the Prime Minister and
again I'm sitting in one of the most
northern seats that prime minister's
been in for some decades I think
delivering on our equipments to the
north is incredibly important but it's
also personally very important to me
because that's where I go home to on the
few occasions I am able to actually go
home these days
um but that's where I go home to so I
don't think you have to worry about that
because you know for the rest of the
cabinet the prime minister is someone
who sits in one of the most northern
constituencies in England I'm on that
train and I was talking about getting
across and getting up and down I live it
I breathe it my constituents live it and
breathe it and I if I don't deliver on
it it's hard for me to go home at the
weekends as well so I think that people
should have confidence that I can crack
on and do that right next if we got
someone from BBC
ah Ben hi thank you prime minister Ben
Wright from the BBC
um Morecambe is one of today's winners
but people across the north of England
and Midlands can see leveling up money
being shoveled into London and the
southeast given to the fact that local
government spending has been deeply cut
since your party took power isn't there
a big gap between your rhetoric on this
and the reality and as the phrase itself
become almost meaningless no I mean I
Ben I just literally I think the same
answer that I just gave to anishka like
those are the numbers right I mean
literally if you look at the funding
look at where it's going where's the
place was getting the most per person
the North West where's the region with
the second the Northeast where's the
region getting the least London in the
Southeast right that's what the numbers
say right of course there are always
going to be places that Miss out right
like we you know like I wish we could
say yes to everybody right my life would
be gosh enormously easy if I could do
that but unfortunately we can't there's
always going to be people who who feel
upset about that
um but what I'd say is that there's
another round of this fight fund and
actually some of the people who
benefited this time around you know
didn't the first time around and then
they improved their bids or tweak things
I think and that that's so people should
realize that this is not the end of this
we you know we've got another round of
this we've had one already and if you
just look I'm standing here I'm in I'm
with you today I'm walking where have I
been this morning I was in accrington
where am I going next I'm going to
Hartley pool and I could just wheel off
place after place across the north that
is across the Northwest specifically
that have benefited from the investment
that we've put in right like I mean last
you know whether it's Berry whether it's
Blackburn whether it's Blackpool today
where you know we've got what else have
we got we've got Rochdale we've got
Southport Warrington
um workington they're all over the place
across the Northwest we've got you know
we'll keep going old and Preston like
you just you name it right there are
dozens of communities across the
Northwest that are benefiting from the
investment that we're putting in and as
I said we said we would do this and we
are doing it and actually this is a good
example is a lot of these projects
people have talked about them for years
right and in this case David has been
doing it for over like almost a decade
right and people have been talking about
these things for years but this
government is actually delivering the
things that people have been talking
about for a long time and I think that's
how we start to change people's views
about what's going on and actually
people can feel positive about the
future
right next we've got someone from the
Sun here I think
thank you Jack Elson from the Sun and
prime minister when you're a Chancellor
you vow to cut income tax next year when
you were running for Tory leader you
vowed to cut taxes even further and as
we learned of this slim down budget many
of your Tory MPS are now asking where is
this Rishi Sue not gone so can you vow
to them and voters today that you won't
put income tax or any taxes up by a
penny before the next election so I when
I was Chancellor I also really preferred
it when the Prime Minister didn't
comment about tax policy and uh and
especially seeing as the chancellor has
been so generous today in funding all
these things the last thing I'm going to
do is make his life difficult and
comment on tax policy but I would say
something about it right like look I you
know I'm a conservative I want to cut
your taxes of course I do right because
you all work incredibly hard and I want
you to keep more of your money so you
can spend on the stuff that you want to
right that's what I want to deliver I
wish I could do that tomorrow quite
frankly but the reason we can't is
because of all the reasons you know
right you're not idiots you know what's
happened right we had a we had a massive
pandemic for two years we have to shut
the country down do a bunch of
extraordinary things that didn't come
cheap and then we've got this war going
on which is having an enormous impact on
inflation and interest rates and you
know that's meant that the public
finances how much we borrow every year
and of a trajectory of our debt is is
not where it needs to be right and the
worst thing I could do is promise you a
bunch of things that sound great but
ultimately just make the situation worse
and for all of you guys in the front
couple of rows here I just gonna have to
pick up the tab right because I don't
want to do that right like my job is to
make sure when you go and get all these
fantastic jobs that we were talking
about that I've left you a really strong
economy where yes we're going to be able
to fund the NHS and schools and all the
other things all the road projects that
we talked about but at that point right
interest rates are coming back down you
can afford to buy a house because the
mortgages are not too expensive right
the inflation we've got a grip of and
it's gone back to where it belongs and
then yes we can cut your taxes so you
can keep more of what you earn but it
takes a bit of work to get there right
and believe me as you saw over the
summer the easiest thing in the world is
me to just promise you the Earth but I
wouldn't be being straight with you
right but trust me that is what I'm
going to do for you this year that is
what we are going to do while I am prime
minister and if we do those things we
will be able to cut your taxes that's
what I want to deliver but I will get
there and that is I know what you want
me to focus on right now that's what I'm
going to do and if we do those things we
can then start cutting your taxes and I
know that you work hard and I want you
to keep your cash all right next right
we've got someone from The Daily Mail I
think
Lord Dyson leading brexit brexiteer
entrepreneur says that your economic
policy is stupid and short-sighted he
says the tax is too high and there's too
much red tape there's growth now a dirty
word for your government and you no
longer believe that tax cuts for
business are needed to deliver
investment growth right well when it
comes onto growth it's right there right
it's number two is what we're talking
about today of course growing the
economy is really important right and
but what does it actually mean in
practice because it's a kind of an
economic world what does it mean it
means more jobs that pay well right
that's the simplest way for everyone
here to think about it I think it has
everyone thinks about it is make sure
you guys all have great jobs to go to
making sure those jobs pay really well
right and you know what about cutting
taxes for businesses we are cutting some
taxes for businesses I was saying to the
lady earlier for all those High Street
shops for those restaurants for those
cafes those small businesses which are
so important to our local communities
like yours we are cutting their business
rates actually we're cutting it now
we're cutting it again starting in the
spring to help them we're also cutting
all the taxes for businesses that are
investing so any of you that runs small
businesses you're going to benefit from
something called the annual investment
allowance which what does that mean it
means that whenever you invest in
expanding your business buying some new
Machinery plant or equipment you can
write the entire thing off against your
tax bill right that is a very generous
thing that we are doing no other country
and you can do up to a million quid by
the way a Million quids worth of
investment because right off against
your tax bill right no other country in
the world does something like that right
I'm very happy for James Eisen tell me
if I'm wrong but virtually no other
country in the world that I know does
anything like that for small and
medium-sized businesses about 99 of
businesses don't spend more than that on
their investment and we want to make it
really easy for your business to invest
because that is how we're going to help
grow the economy because if all your
small and medium-sized companies think
about expanding and growing driving up
productivity creating new jobs we will
grow the economy that way and that tax
cut that annual investment allowance at
the chancellor put in place is so so
General and very important and that's
why I'm confident because you guys will
drive the Ingenuity we need that we will
grow the economy and then ultimately
we'll be able to cut taxes more for
everyone as well right and I think there
was someone local here from Lancashire
live is that is that right yes right yes
Susan Newton from Lakeside hi
um prime minister I saw that you flew to
Blackpool airport today
um on a private jet instead of traveling
by train obviously when there's a
climate emergency and using taxpayers
money
um I was just wondering since you found
Blackpool airport so useful to arrive
here today and access this part of the
Northwest why can't we have the money
for it to be reopened for commercial use
right so you know I travel around so I
can do lots of things in one day I'm not
traveling around just for my own
enjoyment although this is very
enjoyable of course right I'm traveling
around so I can talk to people in
accrington this morning that I can talk
to you and then I'm going to get over to
Hartlepool because I'm working on all of
your behalf right then trust me I'm
working as hard as I can to deliver for
you and that's I travel to make myself
as effective as possible on all of your
behalf you talk about investing in
Blackpool right what have we done we
actually just announced today 40 million
pounds of investment in Blackpool right
they're getting I think actually you
talked about climate change I think what
they're getting in Blackpool from memory
but someone will correct me I think
they're getting a new University campus
that is focused on Net Zero right so
someone should correct me if I'm wrong
but so I think that's what actually
today's announcement in Blackpool is
about it's 40 million pounds for a Net
Zero campus to help us solve the
challenges of climate change in
Blackpool and that comes on top of
actually black will already receive 40
million pounds in something called the
towns fund which was a kind of previous
iteration of what we're doing today
because Blackpool obviously is a place
where deprivation is high and we really
want to transform people's opportunities
in Blackpool and the quality of life and
the MPS there Scott and Paul did a
brilliant job and that's why they were
one of the first places where we we said
look how do we regenerate a town like
Blackpool and they've got 40 million
pounds and actually it was described as
it's partly it highlights the issue but
in a way a good thing it was described
as the king's cross kind of London style
regeneration in Blackpool now that
King's cross regeneration for those of
you that have visited London and seen it
has been extraordinary over the last 10
years but that's all that money is going
into Blackpool to do and I think
actually in Blackpool they're probably
really excited they were very excited
and happy about that and I bet you right
now I'm not going there today to see
them on this that project but I bet you
they're really excited about the money
they're getting today for that campus
because that is going to really create
jobs and opportunity for people there
and it's going to help solve Net Zero
which are absolutely right to point out
is something we need to tackle right
last one sand
thank you prime minister
um your predecessor Boris Johnson
launched the whole leveling up project
because he said that he wanted to help
specifically deprive communities out of
London the South London the southeast
because he said that they were
overheating now it is just a fact in
absolute terms London the southeast got
more than a lot parts of the country
you're concentrating on per head funding
that's a long-term justification for
spending Less on the North that we've
seen across many many decades are we
getting the kind of leveling up that we
were promised in the 2019 general
election by Boris Johnson and is the
thing that's really changed that you're
worried about losing Southern seats and
one linked question are you a hundred
percent committed to the current plan
for hs2 so again it's kind of version of
the same same question Sam but look we
are completely committed to leveling up
across the United Kingdom and we've
already been through a couple of ways of
saying the same thing if you look at how
we're spending this money it is
disproportionately benefiting people in
the Northeast the north west and that's
what that's great right and that is
great and part of what the Prime
Minister said is actually one of the
criterias in this fund it looks at the
previous investment an area has received
because part of what we're trying to do
here is say hang on there are some
places that seem not to get the
investment that others got and we want
to try and correct that where we can and
that's actually one of the criteria for
what we're doing today and we remain
committed to delivering it it's got I
mean talked about the poll politics of
it I think about half or around half the
funding that we announced over the the
course of today or both funds has
actually gone to places that are not
controlled by conservative MPS or
councils from memory it's around half so
I don't think anyone can say it's being
done on that basis there's a completely
objective transparent criteria it's all
online it talks about the things I
talked about with all of you before we
look at a project and say can it be
delivered who had the question about how
long it's going to take right or we like
to say hang on no point doing stuff that
can't work right can it be delivered
this project is it a good fit for the
local area and what's the need of the
local area is one of the specific
criterias and then because you know we
talked about walking I can't do
everything we talk about value for money
right like if we spend a pound here are
we going to get you know gone two pounds
of value back from it if we spend a
pound here and we only get 50p that's
probably less good those are the types
of things that we look at this is
ultimately I'm spending all this money
on your behalf those are all the things
that you probably want me to look at to
make sure that we're putting it in the
right places so that's how we've gone
about it and I'm really confident that
it will make a a big difference but I'm
being heavily waived at so I'm just
going to say hang on I'm just I'm just
Sam thank you I'm just going to say to
all of you thank you hugely for having
me today it's been such a pleasure to
spend some time with a small group of
you this morning when we looked at the
project which is genuinely inspiring I
mean you know I've heard David talk
about it at nauseam for several years
but actually to come here and be with
you to see the unbelievable excitement
and passion that you all have for it and
to know that you're going to create
something very special that the entire
country is going to be proud of it's
been a great privilege for me so thanks
for your time and really go and enjoy
today because good day for you thank you
Richard sunac there speaking up in
Morgan and Lancashire about this new
Eden project uh being questioned by
journalists at the end there but also
lots and lots of questions uh from those
in the area who've got a stake in it
lots to discuss joining us to react with
what the Prime Minister had to say uh is
Clive Betts uh Clive is the uh chairman
of his labor MP for South Sheffield East
and chair of leveling up housing
communities and select committee and
also Henry Morrison who is chief
executive of the northern Powerhouse
partnership which aims to transform the
northern economy uh good to talk to you
both Clyde bets to you first of all
um as a local MP up there do you feel
that the money is going to the right
places
uh no I mean I think the money has been
distributed in the wrong way as well
that's the fundamental problem not
arguing between one project and another
uh I said in the comments today and this
is on behalf of the select committee
what we're doing really is going through
a pretense that bits of pots of money
are going to make any difference at all
however they're distributed I think we
counted about 300 pots of money that
local Council now have to bid for
there's no indication that government
joins up these bids no real strategy
what we should be happening now is that
all government departments should be
looking at the totality of their
spending and how the billions of money
which they spend not the few Millions
announced a day can best be spent to
improve the the circumstances the
productivity uh the services of people
in the most deprived communities there's
no indication at all that's happening
the Secretary of States indicated he
wants it to happen there's no indication
that's happening and these bits of money
these individual pots are not going to
fundamentally change the situation okay
well let's uh talk to Henry Morrison and
Henry I suspect that you you may be
slightly echoing that in terms of how
the money is distributed and the amount
is actually costs for local councils to
bid for this money
yes and I think the the estimate that's
been come up with is it's cost at least
27 uh million pounds just for the
bidding
um and so the reality is that for those
places that didn't uh win this time or
last for instance uh Kingston upon Hull
uh South times South times one of the
most deprived authorities based on
employment anywhere in the country those
Council taxpayers are worse off